Jeremy tweeted six hours ago this is
some bull-ish it says the video has been
removed for violating YouTube's policy
and harassment and bullying he says this
is an escalation of something I've been
noticing in analytics this is why the
Publican now was started I'll make a
video now but consider joining today and
then he says it was a video where I
defended Dylan Mulvaney much to the
Chagrin of many for how mean Matt Walsh
was to him I now regret that and then we
have uh this from Sydney Watson it says
YouTube has deleted an entire video from
the quartering and my community
community notes channel for bullying and
harassment we have to assume it's
because we discussed Dylan Mulvaney this
is exactly why we created the public a
noun and why we are so appreciative of
everyone who has signed up as a member
to support the effort gender ideology is
a Scourge and it's asinine we can't call
it out
so I can only imagine this will continue
to get worse in terms of The Purge